et pierre guerlain c'est un professeur
de civilisation américaine à paris dit
ce spécialiste des états unis gallen
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin à leur première
question comment analysez vous la
dernière sortie de donald trump un appel
au calme mais pas de regrets
je pense qu'ils pouvaient le terran sa
hotte howell dont on connaît par exemple
les déclarations la guerre c'est la paix
donald trump pendant quatre ans et même
pendant la campagne a vendu une chose et
son contraire
il a menti mais aussi n'est pas très
conscient de ce qu est la vérité est là
il dit évidemment tout le contraire de
ce qu'il a fait en incitant une foule
d'émeutiers à anvers le capitole par
ailleurs je pense que il se rend compte
que ça a été beaucoup trop loin et donc
qu'il essaye de préparer
peut-être une défense s'ils se
retrouvent devant des tribunaux c'est il
s'agit de ce qu'on appelle de façon
familière d'un enfumage
parce qu'évidemment il a et inciter des
gens à rentrer dans le capital est donc
à mettre en danger la démocratie
maintenant il dit tout le contraire
alors il reste une dizaine de jours
avant l'investiture de joe biden à la
maison blanche une transition très
délicate ce que vous pensez que on
pourrait voir les deux présidents réunie
ce jour là alors avec top
il ya des surprises tout le temps donc
on ne sait pas si ce jour là il va comme
il est habituel aux états unis faire la
transition et faire le voyage en voiture
avant de bail vient de prêter serment
donc ça c'est des conditions
psychologiques qui vont déterminer s'il
est présent ou pas on peut penser
cependant que comme vous le dit dans le
reportage tous les observateurs sont
d'accord
joppy très isolée fox news ne soutient
plus peines a lâché mcconnell a lâché
dire que la droite américaine y compris
la droite très dure ne veut plus
archer avec toi donc il comprend cela
est le seul pouvoir qui lui reste un
pouvoir de nuisance en activant une
partie de sa base et seulement une
partie parce que le monde des affaires
ne va plus marcher avec lui il lui
resterait peu d'instruments nature donc
pour la transition on ne sait pas s'il
va se se joint à bayonne ou bas mais de
toute façon la transition va se faire
dans la vidéo postée hier soir donald
trump a déclaré je sais que notre
incroyable perry tout ne fait que
commencer on a l'impression qu'ils me
donnent déjà rendez-vous à à ses
supporters dans quatre ans oui mais
alors vous savez en politique
britannique une semaine c'est très long
au politique
là quatre ans c'est très long il a 74
ans on ne sait pas comment les choses
vont évoluer tout va les prendre des
décisions de baden qui a fait un rôle
important à jouer parce que si bayonne
n'intervient pas énormément sur la crise
sociale
tous ces gens mécontents surexcité
aujourd'hui ne vont pas disparaître
c'est ce qu'on appelle le crack bismes
centre centaure donc pour faire baisser
cette tension
il faut qu'ils les mesures importantes
qui concernent les gens qui sont
déshérités et donc tout va dépendre des
politiques de l'administration baydan
dans quatre ans c'est très très long on
ne sait pas vraiment ce qui peut se
poser comme situation par contre on peut
penser que comme va essayer de faire un
type entier à lui tout seul
en créant un média pour continuer sa
série de déclarations inflammatoires
incendiaires voir dans le cas la
politique étrangère génocidaire donc
tout ce qu'on a connu pendant quatre ans
il va le faire en tant que personnage
médiatique
dernière question concerne plus
largement le parti républicain on la
veut ils ont perdu donc la maison
blanche également la majorité au sénat
est ce que les républicains parviendront
à se relever de cette présidence
controversée de donald trump à votre
avis alors il faut quand même voir que
lors des élections de novembre les
républicains ont gagné des voix à la
chambre des représentants où ils ont
gagné des sièges et au niveau des états
la majorité des américains sont toujours
dirigé par des républicains
parmi ces républicains il ya des gens
qui sont investis d'autres qui sont dix
ans de droite traditionnelle donc va y
avoir une bataille idéologique la
bataille idéologique à la lieu depuis
très longtemps parce que le type 1 t
lorsqu'obama est arrivé au pouvoir
c'était une bataille idéologique à
l'intérieur de la sphère républicaine ça
va continuer et tout dépendra de
l'évolution de la société et l'économie
américaine pour juger de leur succès
merci beaucoup pierre guerre-là d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien professeur de
civilisation américaine à paris 10 et
spécialiste des états unis